hey guys it's Justine and today I have
something super exciting to show you
this is the brav oven and I have
reviewed this in the past but they now
have a brand new updated version with a
glass front so you can actually watch
your food cook and what's so special
about this is it actually cooks with
light it has patented pure light cooking
technology and I have been using one of
these for the past I've lost track of
time many years at this point but I'm so
excited to show you this brand new one
and a huge thank you to Bravo for
partnering with me on this video so this
is brand new we still have to set it up
I've still got some stickers on it but I
wanted to show you what is included when
you purchase one of these this comes
with a Bravo glass tray a temperature
sensor and a Bravo metal tray here's the
temperature sensor this is one of my
favorite Parts because you're able to
get perfectly cooked meats at the
temperature that you want it also comes
with this new wireless thermometer now
the old one used to be wired so I'm so
excited about this Wireless one this
will wirelessly connect with your Bravo
and you'll be able to easily monitor all
of the temperature of your food look at
this nice glass tray and the metal tray
there are some accessory pans the co
with it hold
on we've got a loaf pan this is the egg
pan one of my personal favorites I love
making breakfast sandwiches in the brav
we've got the square pan an extra metal
tray the muffin tin and an extra glass
tray but there's one
more this is the chef's pan and it's
made of all ceramic I've used this many
times to make different types of
casseres and it's so awesome because it
just slides right into the brav oven and
then I can also just put this back in
the refrigerator and then use this also
to reheat as needed so now that you've
met all of the pans and accessories
let's set this
[Music]
up oh wow this is so
cool this was one of the most highly
requested things in the Bravo oven is to
add a glass front so you can actually
watch your food cook but this actually
has cameras inside of it so you can
watch your food cook on your phone
something new that they just added is it
will do a time lapse of your food being
cooked and you can download it as a gif
I am so hyped about this so I need to
connect this to Wi-Fi and sync it to my
phone so let's get started first we're
going to connected to Wi-Fi and once
it's connected we're going to do this
initial software update so here's the
dashboard you can control this entirely
from the dashboard here and you can
scroll through find something that you
want to cook and it will walk you
through to be able to make what ever
that thing is so here's where it tells
you exactly all of the steps that you
need to do if you want to personalize it
by cooking longer or shorter the
location of where to put the pan and
then you're ready to go the green button
signifies it's time to cook you can do
so many different things in here you can
sear toast bake reheats Brava air fry
dehydrates you can do rice cooking you
can just keep warm and there's even
procook and custom Cooks I've actually
made a custom cook right here I made a
Justine's breakfast bowl and and I
downloaded these chicken and vegetable
skewers from someone online there's so
many different things in the cook menu
pretty much anything that you can even
imagine they have it here tofu snacks
desserts nuts cocktails condiments you
name it you can even make pizza another
cool thing is they have this new item
section this is constantly being updated
from brav chefs so you always have
something new and fun to try and in the
search you can type in what you want to
cook or you can use some of their preset
suggestions if you want to just use the
chef's pan or the egg tray or if you're
going to be making chicken or if you
want a vegetarian dish it'll filter all
of those out for you some of these are
multi-step recipes which is kind of neat
because this will give you the entire
recipe and when to swap out trays for
different ingredients all of these
recipes are also available on the iPhone
app and you can send them directly to
your oven we got the Bravo all set up my
food prepped and you might be wondering
what are we making today well friends we
are making a fet Manan potatoes and baby
broccoli now I've got the recipe right
here and now I'm going to click send to
your Bravo that's going to automatically
send it here and everything is already
up on the display ready to cook and
here's a demo of how to measure the
steak to get it prepped to get the
correct temperature so I'm going to
follow through this recipe it says it's
going to take about 10 minutes to prep
and 25 to 33 minutes of cook time so
let's get started the first step is to
prep our broccoli and our potatoes we're
going to get some olive oil and some
salt and get these all ready to get on
the
pan
so our potatoes are ready in the recipe
it does say to season them but these
were actually already seasoned so
spoiler I'm cheating the broccoli on the
other hand is not we're going to use a
little avocado oil and we're going to
just give you a little a little
bath so our vegetables are prepped now
it's time to move on to the meat so
we're going to Pat the steaks dry with
the paper towel season on both sides
with some salt and pepper and then we're
going to place them on the pan and we
cook that's it that is all it also says
that I'm supposed to finally chop some
chives but I don't have those so we're
going to skip that
step seasoned and ready for the pan I
love that it gives you an image of how
to lay out your pan before you put it
into the oven this has different zones
on it and they're labeled 1 two and
three so we're going to be putting the
broccoli here in one steaks in two and
potatoes in
[Music]
three we're eating good
tonight this is the meat thermometer now
on this it has a little measuring system
so you're going to put this up to the
steak and then wherever the line is
you're going to match that line with the
line on the Bravo oven so it'll know how
thick the steak is next screen lets us
select how we want our steak I'm going
to do mine medium so now it's telling
you to insert the temperature
horizontally into the
meat so our temperature sensor is in
we've got our meat set to the desired
temperature and really there's not much
left to do but cook we follow the
prompts everything looks like it's ready
to
go look at this look how you can see it
oh my goodness I can see all my food
cooking I can't can't wait to see the
time lapse of all of this cooking it's
going to look so cool and now we have 13
to 22 minutes to wait so I'm going to be
waiting here super patiently my favorite
feature still is the fact that this has
cameras inside of it so right now I am
watching my food cook on my phone this
is great if I need to run upstairs or if
I need to run to the other room or
something I can have eyes on the food at
all times it's looking so
good
I think it's
ready
wow this looks so good I'm also starving
so like I I can't wait to dig into this
let me get some
plates look at my little
meal this looks
incredible also I found this out way
later in my owning a brav that this is
actually a little hot plate so you can
put your hot food right on top of it
okay I'm going to cut into this and just
see how the meat
looks oh wow look at that's actually
perfect that's exactly how I like
it what oh wow that looks so good let's
check you
out oh yeah that's
beautiful
there it is I just made a meal for two
Tyler it's your lucky
day okay here's my first
bite this is exactly how I like my meat
prepared it's perfect sometimes they
make it a little bit too cooked and then
it's like too chewy then sometimes it's
too red and it's still like bleeding
like this is perfect consistency oh I'm
so
happy oh man this is so
good try a little
potato try a little
broccoli I also love how well this Cooks
vegetables it's so perfect I'm going to
enjoy this first and then I'm going to
make some cookies for
dessert
I'm full and so happy now it's time to
make the cookies so I'm just going to be
searching for a basic chocolate chip
cookie recipe I have some cookies that
are already made you could make these
from scratch I didn't do that but there
are recipes that you can choose from if
you want to do
that do you hear M
eating cookies very it
is
heart send to
Bravo 1 to nine cookies this is great
because these are homemade or store
about cookie dough chilled the equipment
that we need is our Bravo metal tray
parchment paper optional I don't have
that you might notice that there's a
small Corner missing I don't know what
happened to that one
really don't want to talk about it it's
in my belly not going to lie that meal
was incredible and I'm not surprised
because I basically cook all of my meals
in the braa oven so I'm not surprised
all right we need to arrange these
cookies 2 to three inches apart my meal
was so good I can't even I can't even
believe it like I want to eat it
again is that 2 to three inches apart
that is
okay there's our cookies so already sent
the recipe to the BR Ava and now we're
going to put them in the
oven can't wait for a
dessert the cookies are done the cookies
are done the cookies are
done this is like a perfect little
cookie I wish I could say that I made
this from scratch but it doesn't really
matter because I made these in literally
like 10 minutes put them on the pan and
they are ready oh gosh and they're
crispy
oh was really hot probably should have
wait from to cool down first
but oh
yeah wow what a perfect meal here you
go oh yeah they're
incredible they're good do you like it
yep Tyler's
hyped these are so good I am so obsessed
with the Bravo if you guys want to get
more information or to purchase the
brand new glass front Bravo I'll put a
link in the description so you guys can
check it out I love that you can do so
many different things in this from
baking to air frying to searing to
dehydrating and this really does replace
so many other appliances in the kitchen
like I don't even really use my
microwave I hardly ever use my oven I
don't even use a toaster oven or a
toaster anymore I make everything in the
Brava it's honestly no joke my absolute
favorite so thank you guys so much for
watching if there's anything you'd like
to see me bake here in the future leave
it in the comments below and I'd love to
try it out I'll see you guys in the next
video bye